nos piden que encontremos la resta y
simplificamos este par de fracciones ok
y esto es muy similar a la suma de
fracciones si nosotros tenemos un
denominador común nuestra respuesta va a
estar dada en ese denominador común que
es 18 18 nuestro denominador común
porque está en ambas fracciones si no
tuviéramos un denominador común recuerda
que lo que tenemos que hacer es buscar
un denominador común y bueno pues
esencialmente como tenemos el
denominador común lo que hay que
tomarlos es la diferencia de 8 menos 5 y
cuando es esto
8 menos 5 es 33 entre 18 ahora bien esta
podría ser tu respuesta correcta
excepto que nos piden que simplifiquemos
la respuesta y para simplificar vamos a
ver si el numerador y el denominador lo
podemos dividir entre un mismo número y
si las respuestas que lo podemos dividir
entre 3 a esta parte lo puedo dividir
entre 3 ya esta parte también la puedo
dividir entre 3 entonces voy a dividir
entre 3 tanto arriba como abajo
de esta fracción y que me va a quedar
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 3 entre
3 lo cual me da uno mientras que tengo
18 entre 3 lo cual me da 63 entre 18 es
lo mismo que un sexto y bueno esto lo
podemos visualizar la siguiente manera
si yo tengo aquí a una caja
supongamos esta caja y después vamos a
dividirla a la mitad más o menos como
por aquí y ahora a la parte de arriba la
voy a dividir entre eso 1
aunque algo así y dos ya aquí la tengo
dividida en tres y de aquí también la
voy a dividir en tres voy a dividir esta
parte un 3
ok y esta parte también me va a dar 3 o
que ya tengo seis renglones y ahora voy
a dividir esto en tres partes iguales
algo más o menos así más o menos así ok
y algo más o menos así más o menos así
me va a quedar algo así ok en un
principio yo tenía 8 entre 18 y yo creo
8 partes de estas 18 partes que tengo
aquí me quedaría una
3 4 5 6 7 8 y ahora lo que nos dice es
que a estas 8 partes de 18 que tengo
aquí le voy a quitar 5 de estas partes
pues vamos a quitar las 1 2 3 4 5 de lo
cual solamente me quedan las tres
primeras partes coloreadas de las 8
partes que teníamos en un principio le
quité 5 m quedar solamente 3 ahora si lo
que quiero saber es que esto sea
realmente un sexto pues podemos dividir
esta figura en seis partes iguales
tendríamos a dejar cambiar la
herramienta tendríamos esta primer parte
desde aquí arriba pero por otra parte
también tenemos esta parte de acá abajo
y también tenemos a esta parte de acá
abajo y también tenemos por otra parte
esta parte de acá abajo y también
tenemos esta de acá abajo ok y por
último también tenemos está acá abajo
son seis partes iguales de las cuales
solamente la primera quedó coloreada en
su totalidad por lo tanto 3 entre 18 es
lo mismo que un sexto